I hope never my life had such a
passionate connection with someone a
proposal twin pregnancies and all the
drama a lot has happened to brie and
Nikki Bella since they wrapped season
four of total Bella's and in a new
trailer for season five fans catch a
glimpse of all that's to come he's
amazing he is just he makes me really
happy which is cool yeah that includes
Nikki's Parisian engagement to Artem I
really like you being a part of this
family and the moment she reveals
drumroll please she is pregnant say
something
of course Nikki isn't the only one
expecting a little bundle of joy do you
think you might be pregnant I'm three
days late are you being serious
brie and her hubby Daniel are pregnant
with baby number two twins pregnant the
same time coming shocked are you shocked
so is mama but it isn't all rainbows and
butterflies the world comes dinner table
brie and Bryan who share a two-year-old
daughter birdie seemed to be going
through a rough patch it's fine that
birdie comes first like daddy comes
number four I hate to say this but I
don't want another child
I know it could be happier I know I
could have a better marriage you think
you and Brian are meant to be don't stay
because you have children of course
this first look at season five came just
days after the Bella Twins announced
they are both expecting I'm gonna be a
mom and I'm gonna be a mom to to help
and Mickey told People magazine that she
and Artem weren't exactly trying to get
pregnant quote it was a total surprise
it took even me a good week to come to
terms with like oh my gosh I'm pregnant
I'm not ready for it
as for breathe Bertie does need a
sibling she said that after seven to
eight months of trying to have a second
baby
she was convinced that her daughter was
meant to be an only child then BOOM bun
in the oven soon you know that's where
your dedication starts even their
pregnancy symptoms are twinning I think
we make a good team brie explained quote
we have definitely felt better in our
lives it's actually crazy because we
both have the same symptoms so we've
been super nauseous Nikki added that it
felt like having a hangover every day I
think what mothers do is the most
beautiful thing they fully sacrifice
their body they sacrifice their life
they sacrifice some portions of their
career I think dad's too but what a mom
does for a child and it's not like over
once you give birth it continues these
sisters really go through it all
together when et caught up with Nikki
and Brie in 2019 before Artem popped the
question
Nikki said her sister put her man
through the wringer it took me a while
thank you but I do I approve you so
sweet
Bertie loves himself it's funny cuz on
our podcast that's this one say we have
Artem on as a guest which I was very
nervous about and the questions she
asked I was like I can't believe you're
a sweet but she talks about some stories
of what a B she used to be to him my
I mean she put him through a lot you're
welcome for protecting will and for
Carrie to be protective and Nikki
well she's come a long way back in 2017
she admitted to et that watching her
sister juggle career life and motherhood
wasn't exactly giving her baby fever
it's actually been the best I don't know
if I would say birth control really
because it's made me no offense being
with Brees the first person I've gotten
to see like for the day-to-day and it
truly has made me think like I love
being spontaneous I love my career and I
don't I don't want to be a mom
[Music]